see ya
hello good evening and welcome to the
latest total war Warhammer campaign
walkthrough video today we'll be looking
at the vampire counts and some of their
unique game mechanics technologies and
battlefield units so here we are a
hundred and twelve turns into a campaign
and we've had some real commotion so far
after planting a flag firmly in Sylvania
and dominating the surrounding vamp
factions of Tempelhof and Schwarz often
we sort of accidentally went to war with
the green skins pretty much every
resource we had was poured into beating
back the four green skin doom stacks and
assorted heroes they attacked Sylvania
and war making the strangest of
bedfellows we actually managed to tie up
a defensive alliance with the dwarfs as
we had a major highly aggressive mutual
enemy during that period the dwarfs also
Confederated with zafar nearly doubling
their settlement an army count and
despite the fact that our corrupted
lands were causing the dwarfs attrition
they chose to sally an army out of zafar
to help us out in the defense of Walden
Hoff here as you can see the dwarfs now
form a solid buffer between us in the
green skins and they've been steadily
rolling them south since leaving us a
period of relative calm in which to
focus on expanding northward we've taken
the town of Essen from Austin Mark and
we're now gearing up for an assault on
Bethan now it feels pretty crucial that
we capture Becca and as north of that
point the Warriors of chaos and the
Norse khun's have been unleashing all
health with armies the Damned pouring
out of the chaos wastes they're putting
the northern part of the old world to
the torch and seeding the land with
chaos corruption so they're hidden by
the shroud at the moment but there's
chaos warrior and norsk and Army's here
seething westward threatening the lands
of the Empire so we need to exploit this
period of calm at our end of the map in
preparation for the coming of this guy
our K on the other chosen now his army
is currently encamped as is the one next
to him probably recruiting and actually
this one seems to be exudative
tentacular effect so whatever is in the
army is likely to be very nasty
so yes bet - is the point at which we're
aiming to draw our line in the sand and
mount the stoutest defense we can muster
after that hopefully we can beat the
warriors of chaos back from whence
came now if we look at our objectives
one of our key victory conditions is to
bottle a holds back up in the chaos
wastes can assure that our K on himself
is at least wounded now that's going to
take some work some powerful armies and
some clever military maneuvering
national campaign objectives also
require us to knock out the empire which
is no mean feat in itself if we wanted
to play for the long objectives however
would also have to take care of
Britannia and tackle that increasingly
vast dwarf Empire in terms of military
might we have a few armies in the mix
but less than we did have after a recent
and rather costly drive to max out our
city development we now have access to
some of the highest tier units in the
vampire roster check in the building
browser in our home city of castle
dragon off you can see that we're now
capable of recruiting tera Geist's far
gulfs and hex wraiths we're currently in
the process of replacing our skeleton
holds with these much more powerful
units provided by higher tier
recruitment buildings in effect trading
quantity for quality and as you might
expect our turn-by-turn army upkeep
costs are therefore beginning to spiral
we're now in a situation where we really
really need to make some land grabs and
these north-east and human territories
are our best hope for that recruitment
for the vamps is done in two ways
like any race you can of course recruit
units from buildings that you've built
in certain provinces the second way is
to raise the dead and this is done
instantly you get them the deter that
you raise them now corpses are plentiful
in the old world and wherever your Lords
are they'll be able to raise from a
limited pool of low tier zombies and
skeletons which will replenish over time
however large battles with high death
tallies tend to cede the ground with a
surfeit of corpses increasing the odds
of higher-level undead appearing in the
pool and once the dust of the conflicts
are settled you'll get an epic battle
sight marker like this one assuming
you've already unlocked access to higher
tier unit types through your buildings
already and if the sheer number of
corpses resulting from such a huge
battle is high enough you may be able to
raise those elite units from the ground
and for here is next to one sort of
battle site and you can see that the
number of dead generated and this battle
must have been pretty high because he
has access to a much wider range of
units including criticals and black
nights
now this isn't just a convenient way to
bolster your armies with better quality
troops when you're far from home it also
gets you thinking about how to generate
rich non civic recruitment zones on the
map maneuver two powerful enemies into
war with each other through some
Machiavellian diplomacy draw them into
mass complex like this and your armies
can benefit from the plentiful dead
Heinrich Himmler was the legendary Lord
we chose to begin this campaign with
Manfred I only came on the scene
recently and here he is besieging Bek
often he's up to level 12 now and we've
put a lot of points into his lore of
vampire spell chain if we want to see
how those spells look in combat we can
simply right-click them and get an
animated view of the spell at work in
the spell browser
on the character details panel here you
can manage the various magic items will
the dialogues and heroes you can assign
any items you've won to the currently
selected character though if an item is
portal assign someone else you'll of
course can Orion to inform you
technology wise we're making good
progress researching the four vampire
homes the book of arcane here brings
boss to zombie and skeleton units along
with grave guard and black nights did
noir owes blasphemous bestiary brings
improvements to various bestial units
such as fel bats dire wolves and var
ghosts master of the swarm is actually
an excellent early win as it brings some
much-needed survivability to your
otherwise unarmored at the slightly
brittle fel bats the lar Mian book of
blood improves many campaign game
aspects such as growth diplomacy and the
spread of vampiric corruption now
corruption is obviously a really
important part of the vampire counts
gameplay and you can find plenty of
detail on that in our recent rally point
video and finally we're just beginning
to make headway into the Leoben
economica which improves crypt ghouls
and Horrors can wraiths hex wraiths and
reduces army attrition damage which is
super helpful when your arm is a monster
on uncorrupted or chaos corrupted ground
we're currently researching soul binder
in order to reduce the recruitment and
upkeep costs of our newly available hex
Wraith cavalry as they are expensive
units but as we'll see there are some
very good reasons for that
among other fearsome high-tier undead
units manfred is marching with some hex
rates in tow so let's take a closer look
at them while the physical stats of the
hex race don't look all that meaty in
terms of raw numbers it's their various
traits which make them uniquely powerful
first off they have super high physical
resistance making them all but immune to
regular or non magical damage they also
cause terror which brings a major morale
debuff to whoever they're fighting but
is their attacks which are perhaps their
most impressive aspects as they do a
combination of armor-piercing flaming
and magical damage the latter ignoring
the majority of regular armor and
enabling hex Wraith to literally scythe
their way through most unit types in
short these are some of the best cavalry
in the game and that is reflected in
their high upkeep cost
a Manfred is also fielding a tarik I
stand this really is the pinnacle of the
vampire counts roster a winged terror
causing behemoth it has poison attacks
and does a staggering 280 points of
armor piercing damage and as if that
wasn't enough it's also capable of
regenerating hit points during the
course of a battle being a desiccated
bag of magically bound bones however it
is somewhat susceptible to fire damage
so if you're facing one a battle your
flame spells will definitely have a
priority target okay we're going to
leave Heinrich and the vampire counts
there for now
tune in again soon we'll be taking a
closer look at these terrifying high
tier undead units in battle
you